this is a real unique experience looks
like Brian Austin Green and Courtney
Stodden have been spending time together
on Saturday the two were seen enjoying
lunch in Los Angeles Courtney wore a
fitted leopard print dress while Brian
went casual in jeans and a Pink Floyd
t-shirt and we're not saying I'm not
saying the sighting comes one month
after Brian confirmed that he and wife
Megan Fox were splitting up after 10
years of marriage and this is our tenth
year of marriage and our fifteenth years
together so we see how that worked out
Courtney is known for her controversial
relationship with actor Doug Hutchinson
the couple married in 2011 when Courtney
was 16 years old and Doug was 51
Courtney filed for divorce in 2018 and
it was finalized in January I wanted
people to hear everything from me and
then this is it in May Brian revealed on
his podcast that he and Megan began to
grow apart at the end of last year
there's the sense of of loss of how do I
go on with this big part of my life that
I've always known and loved and shared
changing what does that landscape look
like like what does that life look like
Brian also commented on recent photos of
Megan with Machine Gun Kelly Megan and
the rapper whose real name is Colson
Baker meant while filming their upcoming
movie and she starred in his Bloody
Valentine music video Megan has
continued working and doing that and you
know she met this guy Coulson on this
film she's working on Megan and I have
talked about him and their friends at
this point and I trust her judgment
she's always had really good judgment
and I don't want people to think that
her or he are villains or I was a victim
in any way Brian and Megan also shared
three children Noah bode and journey
neither one of us did anything to each
other she's always been honest with me
I've always been honest with her but
we've had an amazing an amazing
relationship and I will I will always
love her and
no she'll always love me and I know that
like as far as a family like what we
built is really is really cool it's
really special
[Music]